et maintenant on y tient
ici
chaque oeil philippe val
quand même je vous plains je vous plains
parce qu'être le patron de charlie hebdo
venu dans une émission de télé ce qui
est très rare pour vous et vous
retrouvez ainsi à côté d'une vedette de
la téléréalité franchement je vous
plains on se connaît pas d'ailleurs j'ai
jamais vu mais très joli voilà on plaide
patron de charlie hebdo et être
néanmoins un homme apparemment et
chandler malade
oui oui vous avez déclaré à la
télévision il faut être un bon client
comme ils disent et je ne sais pas si je
suis un bon client
pourquoi parce qu'on ne sait pas à
l'avancé on sait jamais ces choses là si
ça dépend du climat dans lequel on est
dépendant pas de trucs comme ça
un bon client et puis être un bon client
dans une interview c'est pas forcément
écrire des bons lisa c'est vrai il ya
des biens il ya beaucoup de bons clients
qui sont de mauvais écrivain il ya des
gens comme modiano ou sa gang sont
incapables de s'exprimer assez
d'émissions équivaut diallo est un bon
écrivain
alors cette journaliste rédacteur en
chef de charlie hebdo chroniqueur sur
france inter et là vous venez pour un
livre et un disque alors le livre
s'appelle bons baisers de ben laden car
ce sont des chroniques qui sont publiés
chez le cherche midi
france inter qui sont issus de charivari
votre chronique sur france inter ou de
charlie hebdo voilà alors chaque
chapitre est bien rangé
chaque chapitre est un thème le premier
chapitre c'est le terrorisme on a
beaucoup parlé tout à l'heure avec eric
laurent vous observer les réactions 11
septembre
et finalement vous découvrez que pour
beaucoup de gens sur la planète ben
laden est apparu comme un comme un
justicier qui venge le sud contre le
nord
opulent et finalement ces phrases les
américains l'ont bien cherché dans le
cul l'amérique et me dit que tout ça à
éviter quand même de voir leur rible
réalité ça devient de plus en plus
difficile quand on
on critique même l'islamisme pourtant
c'est pas très sympathique de ne pas
passer pour par exemple aux américains
parce qu'on est dans un monde binaire un
monde où tout est facile simple oui ou
non mais c'est pas oui et non voilà on
peut ne pas aimer la politique de bush
et et détesté ben laden c'est le front
national du tiers-monde ben laden
pas mal alors le deuxième chapitre donc
est consacrée aux usa alors vous dit en
parlant de bouche
il n'y a rien de pire que les noceurs
les fumeurs les baiseurs les buveurs les
[ __ ] les truands repenti tient qu'en
fait vous pensé dit que finalement il
pense que la façon dont ils ont sorti de
leur fille rose doit devenir un mode de
vie universelle c'est pas mal ça ouais
et c c'est comme ça les gens qui ont
arrêté de prendre le plaisir ou comme il
vient ils veulent que plus personne ne
jouissent en général plus que voilà il
voudrait partager leurs ennuis avec ses
marques sharks est une [ __ ] repenti qui
a fait fermer les boks ont alors
troisième chapitre sur la religion c'est
est ce que l'homme a recours à la
religion parce qu'il va mal ou est-ce
qu'il va mal parce qu'il a recours à la
religion car je trouve que bientôt moi
je suis athée je suis pas mais bien
souvent je trouve qu on se réfugie dans
la religion et on passe même à côté de
certaines choses
oui dit l'homme à un recours à la
religion parce qu'il va mal mais vous
n'approuvez pas exactement d'accord j'ai
des exemples auprès de moi et je ne sais
pas s est pas nécessaire parce que c'est
tout d'abord sait on
on est religieux avec le coeur a obligé
de faire des dénis comment dire oui mais
bon tout indice tout et tout passe
autour des tours de voiture monsieur
chaussures je signais agrégation ils
vous regardent comme le ravi de la
crèche
alors que la campagne soit il aurait tué
d'une balle en c3 c'est vrai que c'est
plus rationnel ne peut pas diriger le
monde est là enfin serge édito pour un
parent de faire des top 6 vont
probablement voilà exactement dans ce
titre j'en parlerai à la cafet moi je
suis d'accord il ya une phase 2 de
philippe valcq que j'aime bien c'est
d'après la fameuse phrase de deux mâles
rôle le xxième siècle sera spirituel ou
ne sera pas et vous vous dites
le xxième siècle sera laïque où ce sera
une boucherie en gros en tous les cas
ils ont déjà commencé la boucherie de
détail en irak
ouais ça vous dit les grecs qui divisait
dieu pour pouvoir régner sur lui et
c'est par exemple il mettait dieu sur le
linge qui était un nom si on pouvait y
aller à pied par beau temps un sans
problème pour aller vérifier qu'ils y
étaient hésitez pas donc il n'y allait
pas parce que ça il s'en foutait un peu
d'avoir des dieux qui était à la fois
bon et mauvais très humain - crochet
l'humain de dieu et le fait de créer le
monothéisme et de mettre le bien d'un
côté de mal de l'autre
as tu un bordel inouïe parce que l'homme
est beaucoup plus compliqué que j'avais
des demi dieux
j'aimais bien les demi-dieux à bas taux
longs au japon pas
alors chapitre iv donc j'habite 4 sur
leurs racines tariq ramadan vous vous
vous critiquez vous avez l'air du temps
alter mondialiste oui tariq ramadan a
été invité à un forum social européen
grandes réunions altermondialistes je
pense que c'est une connerie ou qu'il
n'a rien à faire là dedans parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraisemblablement d'autant plus
dangereux qu'il est qu'il est beau qu'il
a du charme qu'il est intelligent et et
qui pense pas du tout que l'église
doivent être séparée de l'état s'il
était même discours est ce que tu
arrêtes inquiétudes vos questions vous
parlez de la corse alors vous dites que
c'est marrant parce que encore sont
écrits par exemple terracol sahara
biffera c'est-à-dire terre corse les
arabes dehors vous dit finalement la
basse est considérée comme un symbole de
la vitalité de la culture locale en
france quelqu'un qui ressasse l'infâme
fasciste la seule explication de vous
trouver finalement c'est que beaucoup de
journalistes intellectuels dans des
villes à la ba oui ce qui évite qu'on
dramatise ça mais je pense que c'est en
partie vrai hein je connais des gens qui
ont des villas là bas et qui disent le
plus grand bien des nationalistes et de
la et même des polyphonies corses alors
que ce serait une punition les
polyphonies corses et pourtant j'ai pas
de villas là bas mais je suis obligée
d'arrêter parce que je pouvais plus
sortir dans la rue
tutoiement que de nos fermes et la corse
exactement comme une maison de campagne
qu'on a en france
on y va quinze jours par an le reste de
l'année ça fait chier ça coûte cher
c'est un pouce et le truc qui me
m'obsède moi la porte je m'en fous ce
qui est terrible en corse et dès qu'on
arrive il faut être du côté des
nationalistes un peu des mafieux
occasion bétracq la sphère des démagos
voilà ce fait rêver des matelles
respirer mais ça n'empêche pas qu'il ya
des corses extra bien une réalité
je mets une généralité sur l'île se veut
pas dire que tous les corps se sont
comme ça la majorité des corses
subissent ça avec
beaucoup de tristesse d'accord quant à
des plaintes et il préférerait pas être
pris pour des cons dans le reste du
monde à cause des 10 % qui pensent avec
leurs racines au lieu de penser avec
leur tête les pinces avec des racines
c'est des légumes quoi alors on en
arrivait là télé justement la
téléréalité ce que vous dites c'est vrai
que les gens ils vont plus voter aux
élections ils votent que pour la star ac
et en plus ils payent pour voter oui
c'est vrai j'avais pas pensé croyable
c'est étonnant pourtant c'est embêtant
quand on est malade et qu'on va à
l'hôpital et qu'on est mal soignée mais
s'il n'y a pas assez de fric pour les
hôpitaux vaudrait mieux voter pour un
gouvernement qui dotent les hôpitaux que
de voter pour la star ac et d'arrêt bah
oui on risque plus d'en sortir vivant
des hôpitaux que de la star qui est
l'église il ya un truc c'est que les
fans
enfin tu les verras jamais voté non bah
ils savent quoi faire de leur fric qui
font autre chose il ya un dernier
chapitre consacré au moyen-orient alors
vous dites jérusalem victimes de dieu et
vous dites finalement ce dieu bon le mec
a dit à la femme tu accouchera dans la
douleur un dieu qui n'est pas prévu la
péridurale c'est quand même un connard
donc si dieu fait des erreurs je
n'existe en tous les cas il n'est pas
celui qu'on croit
sinon il aurait pas de lui dire ça ouais
bah tu dire ça jérusalem c'est une belle
ville c'est une des villes les plus
belles qui soit quand on arrive là par
par la route de jéricho tu prend part ou
quand tu arrives toi parce que moi je
passe par là la grande arrivée aux
dérives par le bas et que cette ville
assure blanche sur la colline la drague
plus tard ils vont buste arrivé l'autre
côté c'est à chier mais le temps qu'on
touchera pas à dieu ce sera la guerre
oui il va falloir en parler fars qu'ils
en parlent entre nous l'armée
voilà c'est la séparation de l'église et
de l'état
c'est falloir que tout le monde en passe
un jour par là l'idée le philippe val
c'est de faire rentrer israël la
palestine dans l'europe c'est vrai
qu'israël ils sont déjà dans
l'eurovision et dans le championnat
d'europe de football s'est pas
aussi la turquie c'est vrai absolument
la palestine bon ben la palestine aussi
ce serait pas mal le jour où c'est un
état parce que pour pouvoir rentrer dans
l'europe pour faire la paix faut que les
hommes et femmes et des droits égaux
enfin des tas de choses plutôt
sympathique quand même vous pourrez le
faire on a bien fait rentrer la pologne
voilà philippe hab ça s'appelle bons
baisers de ben laden s'est évité au
cherche-midi france inter
alors ça c'est le livre il ya le disque
publié chez chants du monde harmonia
mundi alors voilà ça s'appelle
bernadette pourquoi ça s'appelle
bernadette non c'est une des chansons
qui s'appelle bernadette dans la dette
c'est une chanson d'amour pour une
poudre une femme qui qui tu peux pas
avec qui ça peut pas aller avec moi
parce qu'elle est déjà mariée elle est
déjà marié avec un type qui qui voyagent
beaucoup métier quand même souvent la
maison joe cocker est entre toi et
bratton mariez dit-elle alors dû
laisse sécher avait su voir sous l'eau
ce faire aux mamies la gazelle
tremblante à vis de deux carrés
derrière des verres fumés chems et du
roi et priant arguments
voilà philippe balle s'appelle
bernadette ses textes et son nouvel
album qui s'appelle philippe val
voilà alors vous êtes en concert à la
cigale de paris le 10 novembre je suis
tournée dans toute la france
alors vous dites quand j'étais petit je
croyais que je chantais parce que
j'étais gay en fait c'est pour être gai
que je chante hé oui c'est comme
respirer c'était être heureux en
chantant oui oui vous êtes intéressé à
la chanson conte votre mère est partie
vous deviez quatre ans à lyon vous avez
pensé ouais vous êtes retrouvé que votre
petit fonal avec 20,78 exactement un
essai là j'ai commencé à écouter
brassens brel du bonheur 1
c'était du bonheur ces gens là le sauve
des vies j'ai dit l'artiste est bien
aussi il ya un troisième produit c'est
incroyable qu'à vous venez pas pour rien
qu'ils ont perdu les années charles et
ag dit c'est génial c'est vachement bien
génial c'est juste qu'avec jean jaurès
est fait par cavanna val il ya ça c'est
génial
voilà ça commence la bal tragique à
colombey ça va jusqu'à aujourd'hui
alors on se rend compte que que l'humour
c'est plus comme avant parce que bal
tragique à colombey aujourd'hui vous
êtes est lynché quoi vous est ostracisé
pour pau pour des années non non je
crois pas bon non non piles et dancings
sont ignifuges et puis non n'en faut pas
croire ça on peut s'exprimer comme on
veut 1 il ya des procès de temps en
temps non plus à exprimer comme on veut
alors j'avais envie de vous faire une
hardy view mais comme c'est vous je vous
faire une entière d'idiot